I got it!
No no no no no.
Where are you guys?
You wanna shoot this meat?
RUN!
Oh my god!
Where are you guys?
Which one is Rune?
I started my... we haven't introduced anybody.
We just went straight in.
Hello everybody!
We are here playing Who-phobia!
Who-phobia, yeah!
My name is Doki.
We're jumping right into it.
You guys missed out the saddest deer limping I've ever seen.
It was so sad.
It's great.
Anyway, should we all introduce ourselves?
Instead of being like, who the fuck are these people right now?
Just a bunch of people yelling, no big deal.
No big deal, no big deal.
Who wants to go first?
I'll go, I'll go, I'll go.
No one was gonna say anything.
I was gonna say, guys?
Guys?
We are all dead, we're all dead.
We all just point to each other and we're like, not you!
Stupid.
Stupid!
Oh my god.
Let's go!
Would you like to explain your in-game name too?
No, no, no, don't explain it.
It's funnier that way.
That's my, that's my, um, that's my government name.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, so Daddy's the last name?
Oh, my game crashed.
Great game, great game.
It's a title, like, it goes backwards.
Oh, so your first name is Daddy.
And then your last name is at Mercy.
It's like Mr., Mrs., Miss, Daddy.
Ishi, Wee, Wombo.
Oh, I'll do an imposter hunt.
That's the one where, like, everybody is a, there's like lots of deers.
And you have to figure out which is the right deer.
Yeah.
I was watching the trailer.
Apparently there's like, there's like a herd.
And you have to like pretend to be a deer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
What the hell.
Let's see.
All right, got you guys.
I invited you guys.
I sort of accidentally made the match public.
So please get in fast before I leave.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
But who's actually playing this game?
Well, now that I said that, people are gonna buy the game that hopefully I'm gonna make another public lobby.
You're welcome, Who-phobia.
You're welcome for the free advertising.
Not sponsored, by the way.
Yeah, not sponsored.
I was like, early access.
Wait.
Hold on.
What is this music?
It's called, yeah, what do you mean?
It's called Hunter Pride.
Art drop.
The music is killing me.
It was going crazy on the banjo.
The trailer is like, orchestral music.
It's kind of funny.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, nada, bum bum bum, bum bum.
We're organized.
We're so organized.
We haven't even finished introducing ourselves.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these deers.
Fanlan Park.
Wait, I think we just...
Oh, my God.
It's just like nada in Japan.
Okay.
Wow.
Who is...
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Who is the deer?
Yeah, guys.
Who's the deer?
I wonder.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
You should have taken a shot.
Who's the deer?
Wait, wait, wait.
Before we get to it, do this, I guess.
Yeah, you should probably...
Wait, you killed me so hard that my stream died.
Man, I killed the game.
I killed the stream.
Stream died?
Wait, where did she go?
Where did she...
Yeah, what...
Where did she go?
Where am I, guys?
I'm scared.
Holy crap.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think I know where she is.
I think I...
Oh, no.
She doesn't know.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
That's so loud.
It's terrifying.
Who is the deer?
She got the wrong one.
No.
Oh, that was a loud gunshot.
Mine's sanity.
I think I'm dead, guys.
Oh, my God.
I've been shot.
Oh, no.
Are you lifting?
Oh, my God.
Shit.
You killed the deer.
Oh, my God.
That's basically what it looked like when you get the deer.
It's the saddest thing ever.
Look at you.
I don't mind me.
Wait, your neck is bent completely.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
Look, look.
You wouldn't finish me off, would you?
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
No.
I'm a hero.
Oh, my God.
Jesus.
I got you.
There's no way she's gonna miss.
She's gonna miss.
Go get shot.
Get him up.
I know you.
Get over here behind the tree.
Get him up.
Behind the tree.
Get over here.
My line.
Stop moving.
I got you.
Just don't.
Okay.
She can't shoot me.
I have tree as a cover.
I have tree as cover.
You were trying to find me.
Are you sure?
No.
I told you.
I told you she can't aim behind the tree.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm just gonna eat her.
I got no aim assist by the tree.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Here you go.
I got you.
There you go.
You didn't even give me a chance.
I got you.
Just keep standing behind the tree.
Don't worry.
No.
Hey, hey.
Hey.
I'm trying.
You're trying so hard.
Oh, there's a deer body blocking.
There you go.
Yes, you have to keep running.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
I have a t-shirt in my hand.
I got aim.
Okay.
Go here.
Get closer.
The tree will save us.
Move.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna...
Get closer.
Get closer to the tree.
You missed.
Okay.
I got you.
She's distracted.
You're free.
You missed.
Stop it.
You're free.
Take that.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
You're gonna miss again.
We got him, fellas.
We got him.
We got that.
Kidding.
Wasn't me.
You got it.
You want to play the swings?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I'm standing.
What is this?
What the hell is that?
You were like wheeling.
What's up?
You've never seen a deer stand on two feet?
Oh my god.
Yeah, never saw that.
Alright, don't worry chat.
I lowered the game.
Holy shit.
This is the game of the year.
Game of the year, Goaty.
Alright, quick, before the game starts, go!
Quick!
Oh my god, wait, who's the...
Oh, okay.
Oh...
You'll never know who it is.
Oh, oh.
Woah.
This is the worst.
Who's the deer?
I'm Sayu.
And I'm the one with the gun.
Oh!
Yes!
Hello.
Quick, come over here, behind the tree.
That works every time.
Quick,
quick.
Oh my god, my neck.
What the frick...
I'm tickling his toes!
There's no way you can't hit me!
I'm tickling your toes!
That's why you have to reload by sucking the...
You can't hit me!
No!
Frick!
Oh yeah!
Anyway, sorry.
We forgot to introduce ourselves again.
We're all so distracted by the deer.
The only person who's been introduced is having my seat back.
Yeah!
Have mercy daddy!
Oh my god.
He killed all the skinwalkers.
Oh god.
Alright, before we start shooting...
Let's introduce ourselves.
I'll go, I'll go.
Hello, it's me!
Have mercy daddy!
A.K.A.
Amelie.
Hello, hello.
I am a voice actor and Vtuber.
Nice to meet you.
You may have heard me in anime or video games.
Such as My Dress of Darling as Maureen or Uta in One Piece Film Red.
Among many others.
That's her!
That's me!
Wow!
We have mercy daddy.
We have mercy daddy?
We daddy of mercies?
Wow.
No mercy will be halved in this deer game.
Sure won't.
Wait, who has the gun now?
Not me.
I think it's Fruit.
No...
Yeah, yeah it is!
Alright Fruit, since you have the gun and could kill us at any moment.
Who are you?
Yeah, I totally have a gun.
Hello, I'm Apricot.
Also known as Fruit and...
I am a part-time frog!
Part-time frog?
When did you become a frog?
I'm a frog.
Since I could go...
That's why she's...
Part-time.
She's still interning right now.
Under the frog ship.
I'm an intern.
I'm a frog intern.
Frog intern.
Alright, hello everybody!
I'm Doki.
A.K.A Doki Bird.
That's it.
There's nothing else.
Good.
Right intro.
Yo!
I'm Sayu.
I'm a Vtuber, voice actor, and...
things.
I've been in Genshin as Saino.
If you wanna hear a dad joke, I got a dad joke book here.
Alright, hold on.
Uh...
Did you hear about the cowboy with dietary restrictions?
He was rootin' tootin' free of gluten!
Oh my god!
I have, uh...
Fans have given me two versions, actually.
I have another book of these.
Uh... and yeah.
That's me.
I've voiced in other things.
But you can look it up.
But yeah.
Hello.
I'm here to, uh...
kill the hunter today.
Or, you know, kill some deer.
Depending on who I'm playing as.
Your team hunter?
Despicable.
Oh my... how dare you.
Do you hate deer?
Do you hate the environment?
Oh wait, it's Monarch?
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can't believe you.
Stop it!
Yeah, that's right!
You're at the wrong territory!
You fucking...
Guys, revive me.
Revive me.
Please, I'm living.
Get in the bush, get in the bush.
You son of a bitch!
I'm in the bush!
Get in the bush!
Wait, up look, up look.
I'm dying!
She's gonna shoot in the bush!
I'm okay.
She can't aim in bushes!
Wait, wait, you forgot to...
No!
Idiot!
Revive, revive!
She's in the bush!
I can't even think of my tears!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I'm not okay.
Wait, did you die?
I don't know.
I'm still alive.
But I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
Why is there scary music?
What is happening?
Yeah, stupid!
Oh, that's like full insanity.
Oh my god.
Oh, hunter insanity.
I was like, what's that countdown?
Yeah.
What's that deer in my ears?
Oh, if you don't kill the deer fast enough, the deer becomes sentient.
That's right.
The deer evolves.
The other deer?
We're gonna grab your gun and we're gonna shoot you.
That's right.
Let's see.
True story.
Oh, fruit's the hunter.
Fruit's the hunter.
Yeah, it ends up talking.
You know what?
I hate more than deer on this place.
What do you hate more than deer?
Ah!
It could be any of us, Fruit.
We could be right behind you right now.
I just hit...
Eating the grass.
And this is the scariest thing I've ever heard in my life.
We could be right to your left.
Or to your right.
Are you following me?
That could be us.
Right now.
I could be right behind you.
Oh my god!
Holy crap!
I'm so scared!
Who's the actual deer?
Who's the imposter?
I wonder if I can fix my FOV.
Oh no, don't.
There is no FOV settings.
I checked.
You think this game has FOV settings?
This game has like...
Oh shit!
You died?
Oh no, don't worry.
I tried to rush her.
Oh my god!
Get behind the tree!
Don't worry!
Oh shit!
She doesn't know.
I found a guy on you!
What the frick?
Don't worry, she didn't know.
Staying to the corner I see.
Stand behind the tree, Emily!
What are you doing?
I can hit my footsteps behind me.
It's so scary.
The closest tree.
The bushes!
Yeah, the bushes work.
The bushes work.
Okay.
Hey, I wonder if that's suspicious at all.
I'm shooting you!
Oh my god!
Relax!
I'm shooting you!
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
I got you!
The sanity!
Oh my god!
It's crazy now!
We have no other choice!
You pushed me!
I need to reload!
Holy crap!
Bro, Fruit, when you...
You are the scariest!
I don't f***ing know what you did!
You flung me to the other side of the f***ing map!
Oh my god!
Okay, we'll do one more of this, one more of this game mode cause there's like four game modes!
There's four different game modes!
Oh my god!
We have now started.
I can't leave the...
My settings are broken!
Can't leave at all!
I'm stuck in the settings!
It doesn't work!
No!
I'm gonna be blind.
I'm blind.
Don't worry.
I have my ears.
Jesus.
I'm shooting everything.
I'm shooting.
I'm like stuck in the...
Oh, you can't see us, can you?
You wanna bully a blind man with you?
Yeah, time to bully.
We're doing that right now.
No!
I'm in bed.
That's right.
You can't see.
I'm in bed.
I can't see anything.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I can't see anything.
I'm gonna eat the grass.
No!
It's hunting season.
Guys.
Guys, I'm limping.
Please.
I'm stuck.
I'm not trying to play the game.
So, Suvi, you are...
I'm in bed.
Guys, revive me.
Eat the grass.
Eat the grass and I'll come back to life.
Oh!
Oh, you're going crazy.
All I see is brown blurs.
I just see brown blurs.
Yeah?
See this?
I need glasses.
I love my glasses.
I wanna revive.
How do you revive?
You need to revive.
I got two layers of settings.
What?
Oh, no.
What exactly happened?
She got stuck in her settings page.
Yeah, cause I'm the...
In your settings page.
Yeah, it's early access.
Alright, fellas.
If anybody comes near me, you're done.
Oh.
Yeah, but the more tears you kill, the crazier you get.
Oh, you're already almost crazy.
So you're saying I should just make y'all stand up?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I'm not Slim Shady.
You think I don't see you in them bushes?
Yeah, that's fucking wrong.
You can't aim for shit.
It's not that I couldn't aim.
It's just that I'm getting surrounded.
Ah!
Oh, my god.
We're gonna stand up soon, Si.
We're gonna be standing up soon.
Get away from me, you freaks!
Ah!
Surround him.
I got stuck in a pumpkin.
Oh, whoa.
You're crazy now.
Crazy on the side.
This is terrifying.
Yeah, this is so scary.
Okay, I'll start a new lobby.
Okay, okay, okay.
So Hunter and Sam.
Insanity.
It's like the more insane you are, like they get up, but then if you get hit, you're fucked.
Yeah, then you lose automatically.
They have more HP too.
Gotcha.
I don't know what stay close is.
I think stay close is...
You get a point if you're in proximity, I think.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you have to figure out who is the right deer.
Yeah.
Like if a deer is close to you.
Yeah, like if a fake deer, the skinwalker deer.
Can I ask what inspired you to want to play this game?
Look, it's very hard to find multiplayer games.
Sure, sure.
No disagreement there.
But I'm just like...
I saw this trailer and I was like, oh, sweet.
This looks cool.
But then when it came out, there was no multiplayer.
It was like, why?
It was like, there's no private server.
So I was like, okay, maybe another time.
And then I heard they recently updated it with private servers.
And I was like, this is it.
This is my time to shine.
You're the one person on Steam, you're like constantly checking.
It's like, I'm waiting.
There's private servers.
You were the one target audience.
They updated for you.
This is...
This is gonna be the next streamer game.
I can feel it.
It's just the private servers.
Last update was March 5th.
I'll give them that.
Biggest issue with the sound setting slider is not having any of that.
Guys, if the devs are watching this, please, we want sensitivity settings.
Oh, yes.
Mouse sensitivity.
Please.
I want outfits.
I want cosmetics.
You want...
I wanna give the deer a top hat.
Yeah.
That's definitely gonna make sure that, you know, that the deer is wearing a top hat.
You're definitely not the deer.
Wait.
But they have to give random cosmetics to the other deer.
Yeah, the other deer have random cosmetics.
I'm not gonna lie, fellas.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
A deer with a clown nose.
We have to go to the hunter.
You see the big beam in the sky?
Like moving around.
Oh, the what?
Sorry.
Where's the deer?
Where's the honey?
Where is he?
He's very close to you.
Huh?
Or am I lying?
I'll never tell.
Oh, those are my footsteps.
I'm gonna instead of my own footsteps.
But I know I'll know of a deer's footsteps when I hear them.
You sound like the guy that did the voiceover for the trailer.
Oh, really?
Maybe I did.
I actually don't know.
You're pro bono.
You heard the concept.
I watched the trailer and I thought there was gonna be voiceover for the hunter.
Because in the trailer he's like, You effin' deer.
There is.
But it's just so quiet.
Oh, really?
Yeah, when you spawn in he starts spewing a bunch of stuff.
But it's so quiet.
All he's like...
Where the fuck is he?
That's what I'm saying.
Where the fuck are they?
I'm deer hunting, not sightseeing.
What's going on?
The moment Si sees just one of us, he's just gonna start shooting.
He doesn't care.
He's just like, Deer spotted.
I'm hunting deer.
I don't see any fake deer.
Do you guys see any fake deer?
No, I don't.
Oh, maybe it's more so like hiding next to him.
Oh.
That's what the crouch button is for.
That's why there's so many trees and bushes.
Oh yeah, there's a crouch button.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, it is!
We have to hide behind him.
We're being paranoid.
I see a deer across the forest just crouching.
What the fuck is that?
I wonder who that could be.
Like, look across the forest.
Look across, you might see me.
Turn around.
I see you crouch spamming.
Oh no, that must be fruit.
That must be fruit.
Yeah.
Must be nice knowing where the deer are.
Yeah, like be nice.
I mean, just give us the coordinates.
Wait, I see...
Okay, wait, that's you.
Dude, I can't even give you the coordinates if I wanted to.
Who the fuck is he?
One of us will find him.
How close are we?
You see, look in the sky.
Look, look, look.
I'll signal you guys.
Look in the sky.
Oh, I see him.
He's really close by.
Oh, there's like a thing in the sky that shows where he is.
Oh, I see it.
He's like an alien.
I see it.
Oh my god, we're close.
I knew those deer were out of this world.
Sia, we're right by you.
We're next to you.
Yes, we are.
I don't need to prove it.
Oh, I see you shooting in your orange jacket.
You're aiming right down to the west.
We see you, Sia.
I actually don't like that.
I don't like that.
Why are you running?
Why are you running, Sia?
Wait a second, hold on.
What are you doing?
Oh, I see you.
You're looking to the right.
I just wanted to see if the sound effects were the same as the deer running.
Like if I ran, if they're the same sounds as deer running.
Why are you running to the right?
I don't like this game.
We could be anywhere.
We could be in front of you.
We could be behind you.
You know what's the worst part?
There's like a radius around me that is clearly that thing you guys are talking about.
You can see it.
Like when I zoom in, it looks like it's a deer.
It blocks out some of the stuff so I can't even see.
Oh.
Oh my god!
No!
I'm back!
He's getting crazy!
Get in!
Get in the circle!
We can come back, Sia.
We come back.
Wait, I respawned.
Yeah.
You can't kill us forever.
Oh god.
We come back.
These deer are fucking crazy.
Don't keep moving.
No, we could be in front of you.
You don't know that.
I could already be right next to you in a bush.
Yeah.
Get in the circle!
Oh.
I sneaked right in.
I sneaked...
Yeah, that's right.
You don't give a terrible shot!
That's right.
You don't know where we are now.
My chat's like Five Nights in the Forest.
We're right behind you.
Oh god!
This is terrifying!
Oh, you sigh.
I don't like this game anymore.
Oh shit!
I won't die you!
No!
It's like the Slenderman.
The eight pages collect the eighth page.
Maybe if I get high ground.
Where is he?
Oh no!
It's only five minutes.
Who won?
How do you know who wins that?
You won because we didn't make you go crazy.
Yeah.
We just made you...
Yeah, we just made you slightly paranoid.
Oh, okay.
Man, I killed that shit!
You feel anxious?
You feel an anxious?
To be fair, the first half of this was us figuring out how to play.
Yeah, true.
Don't worry guys.
If I'm a...
Okay, I know how to troll.
I'm here.
I know what I'm doing.
You know what the...
site looks like.
Okay guys.
Hey guys.
I'm in my neighbor chair.
I'm in my neighbor position.
Did you put your glasses on?
I think you'll need them.
I see you.
Where?
Next to you.
You would like to know where.
You had...
She's coming right for us.
She's coming right to us.
We gotta make her go crazy.
Oh my ass!
What?
Oh, she missed.
She missed.
She doesn't know where I am anymore after that.
I just spawned, bro!
Let me play!
She doesn't know.
She's scared.
I see you running back and forth.
Back and forth.
What?
I see you.
That's right!
Oh my god!
That's a D.
Red!
Oh, there's a bounce!
Oh!
I'm good.
Where am I?
You should...
I'm
locked!
You locked her!
She's locked there!
I'm locked there!
She's going to Zed!
Oh no!
I'm locked in!
Kill me!
Don't worry!
She can't aim!
Whenever they kill a deer!
Oh!
Guys, we worked so hard!
We had to die now!
I see now!
I fixed it!
She just turned to me!
Holy crap!
We worked so hard getting that meter up, guys.
We have to be more stealthy.
So this really is a stealth game.
Where are you guys?
Come out, come out, wherever you are!
Please, please, I have a family.
I have a family of deers, please.
You wouldn't kill Bambi's father, would you?
Guys, you can... I distracted a...
Oh no!
You wouldn't kill the father of Bambi now, would you?
Oh, I 100% would.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa!
He's an asshole!
What do you mean?
Have you not seen Bambi 2?
I think I'm like the one person that saw Bambi 2.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, do you want that?
You put the glasses on!
I am the ten people that watch Bambi 2.
Are you running?
I won't!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm gonna run in a circle!
Serpentine, serpentine!
Oh, it's working!
What am I, a gator?
Oh, shit!
Wait, why are you here?
Oh, it would be great if there were fake deers on this map.
Oh, shit!
Wait, why are you here?
Yeah, but there's lots of bushes, though.
Bushes!
We have the bushes for cover.
I think we might have glitched the hunter and chenny.
No!
No, it lost us the points!
But they stayed.
Holy shit, this one's harder.
This one's so...
The reset is hard.
Why are you hiding in that bush, Monarch?
But then, if we all hide in bushes, she can't see us.
The hunter becomes the hunted.
Why are you hiding in that bush?
What?!
The hunter becomes the hunted.
How did you know?!
I saw your little booty!
I saw your little pixels!
Surely she can't see me, chat.
Well, I know for sure you're not in the circle.
She can't see me, chat.
There's no way.
Where did she go?
Do what?
What are you doing?
Get away from me!
You want to rape that bitch?!
What are you doing?
Whoa!
You can't hit in this game!
Guys, don't forget!
Don't forget, guys.
We can crouch.
She can't.
She can shoot though.
It's okay.
She doesn't know.
She's standing in the open!
Oh my god!
I got launched!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, please, they see!
You don't know anymore.
What's funny is I'm like...
I'm like spamming reload every time I see something.
I'm in the shadows.
Is it working out?
She hasn't got me yet.
Bro, she's so paranoid!
I'm shaking!
I'm shaking in my boots!
Bro, it's like she every Saturday goes out and...
Oh dear, this is not an amateur.
This is not an amateur.
She definitely killed Bambi before.
Yeah.
She's a Bambi killer.
I can feel it.
That's not...
She's a prodigy.
She got me.
Apex Legends, baby.
Dude, I...
I actually do think we may have glitched the insanity a bit.
No, no, no, wait up a little bit.
I saw it go up.
We just keep dying.
Okay, there's 20 seconds on the clock.
Just to test it out.
Monarch, don't kill us.
Let's just be in the circle.
All in the open.
Just to test it out.
She ran past me.
I got a little bit.
We're just helpless little deer.
We're helpless little deer.
We just wanna talk.
Uh oh.
Well, I just wanna talk.
Talking's over.
No one is talking.
Oh my god, I feel like...
Wait, why is the insanity going up?
We're not even playing the game.
Did we spawn?
I was just thinking, one of us spawned into the circle.
I was locked in, baby.
What?
I'm the killer again?
Alright, alright, alright.
We just wanna talk.
Use flashlight.
There's a flashlight?
Wait, there's a flashlight?
I'm glitched in the grass.
This is our chance, guys.
This is it.
We could win.
Go, go, go, go.
She's stuck.
I don't see anything.
Don't you worry.
Oh, yes, yes.
Oh, no.
What's the shame?
Do you hear that?
Clip, clop.
Clip, clip.
I think it's like deer T6.
Go.
Man, we're...
I can't see shit.
You won't see shit.
You will never see anything.
I can't see anything.
The grass is so thick.
The tall grass.
Get out of the tall grass.
She's running away.
While Pokemon comes for you.
Nice shot.
No, die.
I swear to God.
Don't die.
The sand.
The grass.
We're so close.
We can't climb up.
No.
Friend, don't die.
I'm going.
Just hide in the grass.
I gotta go to Candy Mountain.
Come on.
The water is so loud.
Dude, the water is extremely loud.
That's it.
That makes her more paranoid.
Woo.
Where am I?
Where am I now?
We almost got this.
I can't see shit.
You should have called the wild grass when you had the chance.
Wow.
You're the coolest bitch.
You better run.
Yes, right.
Run.
So wait, what happened?
I was like a foot tall.
I was like an ant.
She couldn't see past the wild grass.
Oh my god.
An animated movie?
Oh, when you lost?
No, that whole time.
The whole game.
Oh.
Why?
Yeah, because she was too short for the tall grass.
You know, like in Pokemon.
Oh.
Well, looks like it's my turn, fellas.
Your turn.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, it's daytime.
That's cheating.
You get the sun to your advantage.
I gotta find me an open field.
Oh no!
Don't let him get the open field.
I hear you.
Yeah, you do.
In the bushes.
Yeah, you definitely hear me in the bushes.
I have an idea.
You're still not in the open field.
I'm trying.
Oh, I know you're here.
No, you don't.
I know you're in when I hear the...
I hear the timer.
You hear the timer?
Don't worry.
There's bushes all around you.
How did you see the force peeling?
Yes, walk...
I didn't see.
I was like, where did he go?
Also, it didn't reset.
Oh, that was a bug on the other map.
Early access.
I mean, that's pretty good for an early access.
You hear that?
Oh, yeah, it works now.
Yeah, that's right.
You can't 360.
They made it so much easier for you guys.
You can't say that.
Amelie fucked you up.
Why can't you be more like Amelie?
Why are you running?
Why am I running?
Oh, she reset!
This is a dead line!
No!
Why me?
I just got here.
I tried this, motherfucker!
Oh, no!
We died too many times.
It resets.
Well, well, well.
No, no.
If it is the consequences of our own...
Looks like I win this round.
We can get it back up.
You can.
That's right.
Try to shoot this.
You can't leave this.
I'm out of ammo.
He's reloading!
Out of ammo.
We going for the kill.
I'm a Halo player, not an Apex player!
It's okay.
He can't shoot the tree.
Just like last time.
Oh, no!
For democracy.
We're still in here.
But you don't know where.
Yeah, where could we be?
I wonder.
What?
You're lucky I had to reload.
Shall I find an issue?
No!
It's okay.
For democracy, you son of a bitch.
Tick tock.
Yeah, you're still in here.
It's like playing dodgeball.
I've always been in here.
If you can dodge a bullet, you can dodge a ball.
What do I look like?
Wait, don't shoot me.
What the frick is happening to me?
Oh my god, you look like a spider, dear.
No!
I said dodge!
I'm sorry, I didn't hear the dodge.
There were too many people yelling.
No!
It's a dumb bounce!
I couldn't go anywhere.
Whale.
I can't believe it.
Sy is exploiting.
He's exploiting!
Exploiting?
Hey, don't blame me for the game making an invisible wall.
Lions!
Mons!
This ain't democracy!
You're right.
This is a dictatorship.
No.
God damn.
What are you looking at?
Maybe that jump in the air over there.
No!
You can't catch me!
I'm 360!
Oh dear!
I took you right...
That's right!
You right about me!
Oh my god!
I got one bullet left.
One bullet left.
No more bullets!
Oh, I used to be alone!
No!
He has to cool down!
Oh my god!
What happened to my body?
My body!
The game said stop exploiting.
No, it stopped working.
The timer stopped working.
He stopped going crazy.
He's becoming sane.
Oh no, he's going crazy again.
That's good.
Guys, we can't let him kill us.
Oh my god!
Put him against the tree!
I'm stuck!
What was going on here?
You'll never know.
That's right!
You're in the wrong territory!
What happened to my body?
I'm in the wrong negative woods now.
Yeah, that's right.
You're in the wrong territory!
I was thinking right.
Get out of here!
What?
Yes!
Get him!
You son of a bitch!
I got one of you!
Oh, you did it.
Well, you missed!
Yeah!
That's for Bebi!
I'm on the map!
I can feel!
That's for Bebi!
Chat, they're cheating!
You literally won!
I still won!
No!
Did I find out ping is a thing?
On my end, I literally was under the map.
I'm like, I still win!
He like disappeared from me.
I was like, where did he go?
I think the night maps are the scariest.
Oh, yeah.
For sure.
It's gonna make me the hunter.
I wonder what the proximity chat sounds like.
I wonder what the what?
Huh?
I don't like where I am.
I wonder what the proximity chat sounds like.
Like, is it just the deer running by?
The funny thing is, it's like one of those things where I like looked and there's no way to pick what microphone to use in the game.
Unless you have to do it.
But specifically in your settings?
I can't see anything!
I just hear the humps.
Just hear me right beside you.
Right beside you.
Come on, Fru, be apex!
Oh, we're right here.
I can't with this high sense.
Hey guys!
Can you hear me?
Oh my god, I'm flying off the map!
I don't think you're near us.
Are you near us, Sai?
Hold on.
I don't see you.
Proximity chat?
Oh no, we don't hear you.
I don't think you're near us.
I'm right behind you.
No, I don't hear you.
Well, proximity chat is a lie.
So, next update.
Don't worry.
Actually, add proximity chat.
We're the early pioneers.
Where'd Fruit go?
On me.
My aim is broken, guys!
It's broken!
I broke the game!
It happened to me.
Just zoom in and out.
Oh, this is so trippy!
No!
I hit the tree!
My tree!
Apex!
Apex.
I literally broke the game!
Yo, she broke the game!
There's a chance for us!
There's a chance!
Spawning at the edge of the fucking map!
I can't... I can't like ADS anymore.
You can't ADS!
No!
It's broken!
What?
The water is so loud.
That's why we need to take her to the water.
It's our only chance.
We need to take her to the water.
Push her to the water.
Fruit, you know where you wanna go.
Come on, Fruit.
Go to the water.
Fruit, come on!
Go to the tall grass.
Hey guys, hey guys!
Go to the tall... to your left.
I don't know how to swim.
Come on, Fruit!
This way, follow us, Fruit!
I don't know how to swim.
If you wanna be a full frog, you have to go to the water!
Oh, that's true.
That is true.
Fruit, it's right here.
It's calling your name, Fruit.
Just like the rainbow connection.
Oh shit.
You're almost there, Fruit!
I can't shoot you even if I wanted to because I cut ADS.
Into the water!
Why do I keep breaking my game?
Just head straight down!
To your left!
Fruit, to your left!
You're going away from the water!
I can't see anything.
Have you tried pressing F?
YES!
It's worse!
It's worse?
YES!
Try...
What worked for me was zooming in and out.
Like using the scope again.
I was like, what's in this bush?
And I just see like a huge...
Okay,
we'll put you out of your misery.
I'm like a million miles away.
I am.
I like being a million miles away.
Some maps are tiny as fuck.
And then this one is like 200 miles away from the honey.
Like what?
Hunty?
She's got that aim.
At Apex Legends.
You're going in an open field?
What is this?
You're in the fucking corner!
I just hear the shots.
I'm like 200 meters away.
I'm within all these bushes.
I'm gonna run!
Which is the right bush?
Whoa!
Fruit, what are you doing?
I don't know.
Fruit is so paranoid right now.
I'm so scared!
Hey, how's it going pal?
Hey.
How's it going pal?
Wait, I'm stuck!
Oh my god, my W key doesn't work!
She's stuck!
We got this!
I didn't even do anything!
Hey, I don't need a W key to shoot.
Damn, that's crazy.
I was just watching your back.
And this is the thanks I get.
I'm gonna reload.
You're jumping in so funny.
You're jumping in the funniest looking thing.
Come on, Fruit.
This is not like you, Fruit.
You wouldn't kill a deer, would ya?
You wouldn't kill a deer with glasses, would ya?
You wouldn't download a deer, would ya?
Oh my god, my gear!
Wait, I died and my scope is perma- I'm perma-sculpted.
Wait, is she perma-sculpted?
No!
We're so close!
The sense is alive!
That's actually right.
She doesn't know.
Oh wait.
Oh no, don't walk away from the bushes.
Come on.
Fruit doesn't know.
You don't know.
I don't know.
Come on, we're just- Wait, I don't.
I'm stupid.
We're just shooting.
No!
Every time we get close, she shames us!
That's right.
That's like you're right.
Back into the bushes I go.
No!
Wait, I found them!
The closest we got was getting Amelie crazy.
That's the closest we ever got.
No!
Will I ever get to be the hunter?
Have you even been a hunter yet?
No, I've been zero times!
I've never gotten a chance to be a hunter!
Doki, it really hates you.
Can the host not be the hunter?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe that's why.
That would make a lot of sense.
I say as I'm the hunter.
I'm the hunter now.
Alright fellas.
Time to bully the shit out of Doki Bird.
Let's go.
Oh my god, bro.
The flashlight fucking sucks.
What the fuck?
It's so bad!
It's so bright!
Hey, deer in headlights?
What?
Wait, wait, wait.
I understand now.
Please!
I'm sorry for bullying all deers before.
Oh no.
This is for my cousin Bambi!
Join Bambi in heaven!
Wow, thanks.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Gotta be alone.
Oh my god, now I know.
Now I know.
Oh my god.
It's like a fucking flashbang every time.
Oh, there's so many of you.
Oh my god, you should see how funny the 360 jumping is.
No!
Oh, just...
Oh god, where's the other deer?
Why are you jumping?
Jumping at a deer?
If I jump, maybe you won't clip my hip box.
Hold the sword!
Oh my god.
I keep moving.
They won't know.
I see you in the bushes.
I know you're in the bushes!
We're always in the bushes.
I know what to do.
Into the water I go!
That's hacking right!
I see you in there.
You're in that bush!
I'm strafing!
She's tap strafing!
That's hacking right.
I have aim assist.
I know you're near me.
Behind you.
Oh, Doki.
Behind you, Doki.
No, no, no, no, no!
You're not in my circle!
Maybe I'm in that bush right next to you.
There's a bush next to me?
There's no bushes next to me.
You're in an open field, you chicken!
That's hacking right.
No!
Yes!
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
I said behind you.
I'm flogging, I'm flogging.
No, no, no, no.
There's too many trees.
We're in the trees.
Looking good, Doki.
Oh god, oh god.
Where are you?
I can't go!
Has the paranoia settled in yet?
It's okay.
One of you will go down.
As long as I bring one of you down.
Yes!
Run, run.
Where are you running?
Away from you.
I see you, I see you right there.
I see you to my left.
You think I don't see you?
Now you're to my right.
Are you sure that's me?
I'm pretty sure I killed the other two.
You're the only dear left in the world.
I'll make sure you all go extinct.
Really?
Cause I'm the one right in front of you.
Oh, you're serpentine-ing.
I see you serpentine-ing right now.
That's right!
Serpentine!
I told you, you weren't alone.
I warned you.
You know what?
I'm gonna do a 360 no-scope.
Where did you come from?
No!
Woah!
Did I hit anybody?
I
didn't get to play.
Oh!
Okay.
Reload, reload, reload, reload, reload, reload!
Yes!
Okay.
You can do this, fellas.
Oh my god!
My couple's got you!
Serpentine motion!
Serpentine!
There's so many serpentines!
Give me a lot!
There's a lot of bullets firing.
Fuck em up!
Oh my god!
Please!
Just bob and weave, boys.
Oh god.
Oh no!
I'm so far away.
Wait, who left?
What happened?
There I go.
You all went way too quiet for this game.
Everyone just stopped laughing.
Okay.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
You can't run that fast.
Just maneuver.
Oh, the bobber!
Oh, fuck!
Hello!
Leave me alone!
This is just our hobby!
Oh my god!
Leave me alone!
There's a new cow tipping!
Oh shit.
You have like a mastiff.
Fuck!
I always miss the one deer.
I get two.
Two is my limit.
Fellas, I don't think we're gonna be able to do it.
Yeah, that's true.
You guys, if we're not being stealthy, that's for sure.
Alright, let's bully the fuck out of them.
No!
Please!
I'm just doing this for a hobby!
We're gonna be so dumb!
Yeah!
That's making me right.
Dear Hunter Superior.
Alright, let's do the next game mode.
This is the next one.
Alright, alright, alright.
Now that you said I've never been Hunter, watch you be Hunter like ten times in a row.
What's gonna happen?
Oh no!
Hit and run.
Connection failed.
Yeah, I was the host.
Switch game one.
Who wants to be the host?
Oh wait!
Let's see.
Let's have Fruit be the host and see what it's like on EU ping.
On EU ping?
Really?
EU ping?
Let me see.
This will go swimmingly.
Oh no.
Have mercy.
It's okay.
As long as we're not Hunter, you'll be fine.
Oh god.
No, the 200 ping.
200 ping on EU servers?
Nah.
There is a single player.
There is a single player mode by the way.
How the fuck is there a single player mode?
The deers are the NPCs.
They're all imposters.
Are they all NPCs?
Yeah.
It's like deer hunt.
You can't trust nobody.
Wait, I said...
Oh, I got it.
Sayu?
Yes?
Oh, wait, wait.
Can we add?
Maybe we can add them to the party.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, well I confirm for future.
This is a great game.
Good job.
Yeah.
Add more game modes.
Give us more setting options, please.
I know.
More game modes.
What if there was like a back room?
It's deers but the back room.
Party leader matchmaking.
Oh, matchmaking?
Oh, wait.
You're supposed to do create match.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, they invite us again.
I love how there's deer emotes.
I can't wait for the cosmetics.
There's deer emotes?
Yeah, yeah.
One, two, and three.
Wait, really?
Was that how you guys were shaking your booties?
Yeah.
That's how you shake the booty.
Eat the grass.
Alright.
I'm in.
Hit it red.
Let's go.
Let me in.
Get in here.
The good old banjo.
Yup.
Let's do this.
I can't wait to put deer ready up.
I can't wait to put our little hats on.
I'm ready for democracy.
Deer-mocracy.
Let's go.
Who's high?
We're going to school.
High school for deers.
So...
Oh, brother.
Hit and run.
Is this like DVD?
Is there an inside and outside?
Oh, I wonder.
I'm eating the grass right now.
You don't know where I'm...
I'm in this court, you say.
So we have to stay outside of the bubble, but we have to hit...
the hunter.
Wait, it's just us.
I just realized it's just us.
That's right.
Finish him!
Oh, what the fuck?
Where is he?
Oh my gosh, he's so low!
There's like a little boss.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's right.
Yes!
Stay inside the bear!
That's right!
Oh, he gets less!
We just had it!
No!
That's right.
You don't know where I'm...
Don't skin me, please!
No, I'm getting skinned!
But escape!
We have to escape the boundary!
Oh my god, you just kicked someone!
Alright, I'm out, I'm out!
I got the point, I got the point!
Nice, nice.
I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck!
Wait...
Ow!
Who is he?
Oh my god!
What happened?
Oh, do we have to stay in the bubble?
Oh...
No, he killed all of us!
No, he double tapped!
He double tapped me!
And now I'm gonna skin you!
Ow!
What the fuck, dude?
What the fuck?
No!
Good thing I blend in with the ground.
Oh shit!
He like...
I'm sorry, we have to stay in for the point!
We have to stay in!
Nice!
Escape!
We have to escape!
No, no, we have to stay... No!
We lost the point!
Oh, we got the point, nice, nice, nice.
I'm scared.
I see you, I see you!
Yes!
Save me!
I see you looking this way!
That's right, you can't...
I can't see!
I notice you can't shoot me when I'm 360!
Don't skin me!
That's a good...
No...
I'm gonna skin you out here!
Got it!
Got point, got point!
If you'll excuse me, I'm skinning my brain.
No!
If you'll excuse me, I'm trying to skin my...
No, no, no!
I'm trying to skin my brain!
You're never gonna skin her!
I did it.
No!
Run down!
Don't let him skin me!
I'mma skin you!
No!
Don't let him do it!
My skin is worth so much money!
I'm done.
I was like, what are you doing?
You can see me?
You can see me now?
No!
I just...
Frank, you let it do me!
Give me your flesh!
We gotta fight, we gotta fight, we gotta fight!
We gotta fight!
I'm skinned!
Can you see the beer?
Through walls?
No!
Where is he?
He's over there.
I'm a pot car.
How the fuck?
That's right, I was always behind you!
Wow!
You're lucky I'm a bad shot!
You guys are lucky I'm a shit shot!
I'm glad I'm not the hunted.
I just got up, baby.
Yeah, that's right.
You're gonna let yourself get bullied by a herd of deer.
Wait, if you hold space...
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
Hey.
Oh, that's right!
You let that 360 spin fucking try!
He let me have this one.
Oh no!
Don't let him see you!
I'm a skater!
No!
Not my foot!
I can't see you anymore!
I'm trying to skin you but it won't let me!
That's looking right...
Holy shit!
I look horrific!
What the hell?
Don't worry guys, another point.
I realized...
I got shot.
Oh, I'm reloading alright.
Where am I going?
The game is broken, hello?
What's going on?
The game looks like...
The skin looks really graphic.
It's okay, I'm right with you.
E!
You can't E anymore!
Okay...
No!
So close!
He got a triple!
We're winning though!
He can't skin us all!
He can't skin us all in time!
Why are we spawning one?
He missed out!
He missed out on my skin!
Excuse me, I'm trying to skin my catch.
No, you aren't!
No skinning your catch here!
Now you don't know where I am.
I think.
I can't move my camera but I think.
He's gonna open!
That's right.
You don't know.
I'm in the bushes.
I'm a bushman.
Get off me!
Oh shit!
Wait, can we not knock you over when the thing is up?
I think if you only knocked him once, you can't do it again.
That's right!
Oh my god!
He did it!
Wait, he skinned me and then it ran away?
Wait, you skinned the wrong one and skinned the one alive one but you still skinned the one alive one?
You skinned me!
Oh my god!
I'm so fucked up!
This game dog.
He just skinned the closest to you.
Oh my god!
My true form.
Where is he?
Where could the hunter be?
Who could it be?
Get away, Prue!
Aren't you having a great time, Prue?
You can't hide from that tree!
Yeah, that's right!
Wait, this tree is back.
Oh shit!
Don't let her near me.
She doesn't know where I am.
Where my body is!
Guys!
No!
It double-tacked me!
Don't eat my body!
She's not getting near my body.
She can't get the point.
I'm trying to get that point, fellas.
Don't let her get that point.
Don't let her get close to me.
Don't let her touch me!
Zero point for you.
Yeah, you better run.
You better run!
I was so fast.
Yeah, you!
Oh my god!
I was scared to live in Cripple Bay!
I was on your ass for a good five minutes.
Oh...
That's right!
Yes!
That's right.
You can't shoot...
Come on, try to shoot me here.
Oh my god!
That's right!
Try to shoot me, Prue.
Come on!
360!
Oh, that's a lot of wasted ammo there.
I know I lost!
That's a lot of wasted ammo!
Oh!
Shit!
Guys, don't let her touch me!
Guys, please!
Don't let her touch me!
Don't let her give me a lot of...
No!
My skin!
My beautiful skin!
My flesh!
The bubble is...
Oh, look at this!
I'm not gonna go in there.
So you gotta like, hit the hunter, stay inside the circle, and then leave.
And then you gotta stay in the boundary, and then after...
Oh shit!
You guys traded!
Yeah, you have to like...
Make sure you kill the deer that hit you.
So they can't get the point.
I can't see anything!
That's good.
I thought we were like, nice!
More points for us!
Did you know that as a deer, there's a suicide button?
Yes!
Wait, what is this?
Oh wait, there's a bugged deer right here!
No, no, there's no deer!
It's me!
It was me!
I missed my open meadow!
I'm gonna go home!
No, don't worry, I'm gonna show you home.
Blackfruit!
We know you're here!
The moment you get up, you're gonna get shot again!
Into the bushes I thought.
Wait, oh no, my ADS broke again!
It's perfect again!
That's right, good.
You shouldn't have told us that.
Free points for us!
Where are you, sons of bitches?
Oh no, where are we?
I smell you!
I got another point!
You're not my ADS, don't worry!
You don't need it, Fruit!
I need it!
I don't smell shit!
It doesn't work, it doesn't work!
You're better than this!
Come on, you only got three of us!
Come on, Fruit!
My head is sticking out!
Well, my head is not sticking out anymore.
Dude, Fruit, in the last one you literally walked over my body like twice.
Whoa!
Will you get back at me?
It's real, it's real!
I got an ADS!
No, he can see that!
My butt popped out of the bush!
No, please!
Don't let it get me, guys!
Don't let it touch my skin!
It bit my skin!
Hey, I'm sorry, I'm trying to get his points.
Wait, how many points did you get, huh?
Huh, Sy?
How many points?
I'm pretty sure like four or five.
Get back here!
And I'm about to get us another!
You're welcome!
You son of a bitch!
That was my friend!
Don't worry!
Get the other bushes!
Don't let it double tap!
I got you!
No audio!
Man, that sure sucks!
Your skin got ripped off!
That's crazy!
I'm so crazy!
I can't do anything about your skin!
No!
Man, your skin fell off!
That shit's wild!
Oh my god!
Don't double tap!
You could say it was buck wild!
Why the fuck did I do that?
Who let this guy in here?
I'm hearing stuff!
Hey, what's good, fellas?
Head on my knee, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna be right here.
Shit!
Guys, I think we're losing our touch, guys.
She's getting better.
She's improving!
She's getting better!
Oh my god!
She's adapting!
Apparently, my last point didn't count.
I just wanna let me know.
She's adapting!
She's gaming!
She's using Apex!
I am so close!
Oh my god!
I'm hip firing the whole time!
I'm keeping her!
I can respawn and she won't get my skin!
I got it!
She got my skin.
Oh shit!
My ankles!
Top 10 fruit noises.
Here we go.
We did it!
We won!
I could have been peeled off, but I won!
That was so close!
You can't catch us off!
I figured out the game too late!
You can just jump over my head!
That's the strat!
Oh no!
Not the night map!
Oh brother!
Not at night!
Not the night map!
Not at night time!
Please!
I don't wanna be hunted!
Oh thank god!
Brother!
It's me!
Sucks to be you!
Sucks to be you, Sy!
Yeah!
I'll help you and draw your vision beam!
Where are you?
I hear them!
Oh that's it!
How do you get the spot in the open?
You have no son to help you now!
I hit him!
Why is your tea bag right in front of me?
Oh shit!
Where do you live?
I got a little copy.
You don't know I'm in the dark!
No he knows!
Now let me skin you!
Don't touch me!
Please!
It won't let me.
Oh there we go.
Look at my beautiful skin!
I have a very long skin routine!
You ruined it!
Your beautiful coat!
No!
I will avenge you!
Will I make this make a pretty coat?
Will I?
Thanks for your flesh!
That was so close!
You almost saved me!
Okay wait wait I see him.
Don't worry I'm coming over.
Guys we don't have any points!
We gotta up our game!
Get him!
I got a single!
Guys I got us some points but not for us.
You tried!
Get on the ground and let me skin you!
No!
I didn't get us the points.
I got a single point.
We did it!
You're the clutch!
You can't see shit!
The blue does not help fellas.
That's great.
My zoom does not work anymore.
That's right you got the fruit nerf.
I sure did.
Looks like we're no scoping everything.
Gotta get higher and all.
Nevermind my zoom works now.
Oh my god where is he?
We gotta beat him up!
Beat him up!
My camera doesn't work by the way so I need to...
Get him boy!
That jump shot!
It's okay don't let him near me!
Don't let him near me guys!
Don't let him near me!
Someone hit him!
No!
Yes!
Get him!
You sumbitch!
We found him!
Don't let him near me!
Get him away from me!
He's gonna do it!
No!
Get off of me!
You bastards!
I lived!
I can't believe you fucking disgusting deer!
We did it!
That's right.
Deer together strong!
And this is some great age bullshit!
Oh dear!
Oh my!
Okay guys I realized running straight on...
was not the right idea.
You gotta bob and weave!
I didn't...
You're a sumbitch!
I didn't really...
bob and weave.
Guys I think this map might suck as a hundred.
Wait really?
Really?
No way!
The insta skin?
Oh my god!
The night map is bad for the hunter?
No fucking way!
Who would've thought?
He missed!
The bob and weave!
The bob and weave is pissing me off!
Bob and weave!
That's it!
That was actually fucking hilarious.
What are you guys doing?
It's upsetting me!
Woo!
There's no more stealth it's just bob and weave.
I'm scared!
I'm hungry!
I just want my deer skin!
You're at F4!
Don't you have enough?
Is F4 not enough for you?
Get over there!
No!
Fruit!
I'm not gonna lie, here's the weird thing.
The body glitches so I don't even know where Fruit's body is.
Yeah I can't move.
Go!
Get over here!
Did you see me crouch back?
Yeah!
Yes I did!
That's how he found you!
I can't help you!
I have to escape the battery!
It's for the greater good!
Oh if you hold space it's pretty pog.
Give me your flesh.
Boom!
There you go!
That's right!
Bob and weave time!
Bob and weave!
Where do I go?
Oh my god!
I gave you that point.
I felt bad for you.
My E button isn't working so...
Wait that means the body is just somewhere else.
No.
It won't let me harvest!
Is the body somewhere else?
It's a skill issue.
I think.
This game might...
This game might suck.
Just because you're bad at the game doesn't mean the game sucks.
Yeah!
I'm pretty sure that's the definition of a game suck you guys.
I think this game has been great so far.
And I've been enjoying my time as a dick.
Bob and weave!
I just said I got stealth 100.
Stealth 100.
Yeah I see that.
It's definitely user error.
I missed a point!
We have to go back.
That's right.
Bro.
I only have half a point.
Not even anymore.
I'm just shooting the button.
I was watching Simon's all his shots in front of me.
I'm not even zooming in anymore.
I'm just doing it.
No!
Apex is looking kind of weird right now guys.
This new season is smacking.
I like fell through the map.
You're not getting any skin.
No!
Yeah!
I still got to shoot you.
We did it!
Yay!
I'm saying a slot though.
You want to do one more then posture one?
I think that one was a fun game.
I'm so happy.
I got to hear my favorite fruit noise.
Which is...
Are you?
Who's making that lobby?
Who's making the lobby for...
For imposter.
Someone else.
I can do.
Create match?
Yeah.
Wait a second.
I think I fucked up.
Wait.
Invite friends.
You got this.
She's got this.
I'm my own teleport.
Half mercy daddy invited me to some bullshit.
Wait.
Hit and run was not right.
It's the...
Sorry.
You're learning.
Hit and run.
Imposter.
I got it.
Don't worry.
That one is so fun.
This one you can use emotes.
I'm in.
I got this gamers.
Don't worry.
I tried at the end but then they fucked up.
I'm in.
On the first one.
I'm more important than all of you because I'm the first one.
I got it.
First is the worst actually.
Second and third are better.
My antlers are better.
Yours are bigger than yours.
You wanna prove it?
I have so much testosterone right now.
I have so much.
I've got so much.
That's right.
You wanna measure our antlers together?
I've got a huge pair of antlers right now.
My antlers are at least 10 inches.
Come on.
At least.
It's not about the size.
It's how you use your antlers, fellas.
Alright.
It's the motion of the ocean.
Right, guys?
We can't even go in the ocean.
What are you talking about?
I can't swim.
Oh, the school.
The school.
Man, I sure hope I don't have a gun between my hands.
I mean, I don't have a gun.
I mean, hooves between your hands.
Oh, I know.
The one deer that instantly ran.
No.
I have no idea.
Oh my God.
What's happening?
No idea who that could be.
No idea.
I have no deer.
No.
That's a fucking wrong deer.
I have no deer.
Wrong deer.
I'm sure you can make it into a pun.
I'm out!
This shit is so scary!
It's so scary!
I heard him say, I'm gonna fucking get you!
You ain't getting shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, you're already insane?
I shot one deer accidentally.
You're gonna go insane.
No, no, no.
Just no way.
Come on, no way.
What is the countdown for?
I know one of you is the deer.
I know one of you is not real.
You're not real.
I took my meds today.
I know one of you is not real.
Are you real?
Let's test that theory.
Oh no.
Which one is it?
I was trapped in a room once.
Are you real?
Are you a real deer?
You're a real deer.
Oh no.
Who's not real?
I can see them in my wall.
How do you know, Anna?
Everyone's a real deer until they're not.
How do you know?
I was crazy once.
Let me out.
Where even are you?
Grab your room full of deer.
You'll never know.
Oh my god, why are you following me?
Why is this the only one?
Two deer are following me.
There's a lot of deer following me right now.
You know what?
I'm sick and tired of waiting.
Me too.
Run!
I got rushed.
Someone call the ambulance.
Lori!
Help.
Where did he go?
We're delicious.
This is the last one.
Look,
I killed Ron.
I saved his life.
Yes.
No!
Get away!
There's two of them!
What the...
Ah, fuck my ankles!
Oh, there's one left.
He's wiggling it.
Oh my god!
This isn't terrifying enough.
No, it isn't!
Woo!
Yes!
Ah!
I can't die!
Yeah!
I cannot die!
Oh no!
No!
I did it!
I thought I'd poke my head.
Is foof-phobia a real thing?
Bro!
It's like Phasmophobia.
Yeah.
I can't wait for the deer to appear in Lethal Company.
How tiny is your garden?
Now, hold up.
In Lethal Company, that actually would be terrifying.
Just ahead of a deer.
Just ahead of a deer hunting you.
Chasing you down.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna go insane.
This is an awful map.
Holy crap!
I'm gonna shoot!
Oh fuck!
Which one is the right deer?
Yeah!
You!
Which one is it?
Why are you staring at me?
That's why!
Yes!
No!
Don't get her!
I got stuck in the wood!
Guys, I got stuck on a tree.
Slap it in the wood!
Where's me?
That's right.
There's no way.
He doesn't know.
No!
He doesn't know!
It's up to you!
I'm not heading... Just so you know, I am not walking towards Sai.
Just so you...
I think I killed Sai.
Just so you know, I'm not walking towards Sai.
No, you killed me.
I can't double shoot you.
Oh shit!
In my defense, the tree trunk got in my way.
She did it!
She won!
For the hunters!
That map is so hard!
That tree really fucked me over.
I gotta say.
My hoof got stuck on the branch and I couldn't...
I told you it's not about the size!
It's how you use it!
It got stuck!
My antlers were too big!
He's running already!
I don't know who's running already.
Hey, is that Amelie?
Right there?
Where?
I'm gonna shake my booty!
Not me!
I'm shaking my booty right now!
You're too close!
Oh, it's Sai?
Oh, Sai...
You're too close.
I'm gonna shake my booty!
I have an idea!
Hey, that's my joke.
You can't...
I stole it!
It's my nail!
What the fuck?
Yeah!
Oh, you're so paranoid!
You're like...
It's like that old man in the house!
You're so paranoid!
You'll never get me, you son of bitches!
The government can't catch me!
That's why I never pay taxes!
I'm off the grid!
I'm going on the swim set!
Swing!
I don't know anymore!
Shit!
Is it you?
It could be any of us.
There's so many of us.
Turns out you're all in the fucking bank.
I don't know who could it be!
You're too close, man.
You're too close!
You're too fucking close!
No!
You have to wait!
There's a timer!
We can't kill him yet!
Oh no!
It's okay!
We can get close to him again!
Oh no!
Just keep walking!
Oh yeah, I'll walk!
I'll walk after you!
There's so many of us!
We don't know!
He's shooting random deer now!
He's shooting random deer!
He's nervous!
He's scared!
He's so scared!
He's so paranoid!
He doesn't know which one's the right deer!
Come on, Sayu!
You love gacha!
Just choose one!
It could be any of us!
Come on!
We're all in your favor!
You know what?
The gacha rates?
I think the gacha rates is in your favor right now.
I've seen you pull.
You've been pretty lucky.
No, I have not!
Prank!
Don't be a coward!
Take a shot!
That could be me right now!
Take the shot!
You're on the floor!
Take the other shot!
I'm texting you right now!
You should take the shot!
Test your gacha!
Don't you wanna look at my...
Test the gacha!
Test the gacha right now!
Quick!
Oh yeah!
There's so many of us here!
Yeah!
Take the shot!
I'm rezzing!
I'm rezzing right now!
You're not rezzing!
You're not rezzing at all!
You're not see me rezz!
Wait, why do I keep getting the E to revive?
Why do I get a silver?
Take the shot!
Take it!
Oh my god!
Holy crap!
Nice gacha, idiot!
No!
Yeah!
It was an early pull!
I still take that as a win.
That's crazy!
That's a win in my book!
That's my win!
Oh!
Have we played on this one?
Oh, we haven't?
I think he got a pity there.
That was a pity pull.
That 100% was hard pity!
Oh!
We know who it is now!
I'm scared!
A gun isn't enough to hold you back!
A gun isn't enough!
It's nighttime!
Welcome to the circus!
I just came to see a funny clown!
Welcome to the circus of value!
In the end, it was you!
You were the clown!
Kill the clowns!
Where is she?
Wait, where is she?
I can't find her!
Why are you getting close to her?
Who are you?
Oh, I see her!
Oh, I see her too!
Stay away from me!
Fuck!
I'm right next to you!
I'll come out wherever you are!
Fruit, look behind you!
This is so funny!
Wee-oo!
Look behind you, Fruit!
Why are you running?
Oh my god!
She screams!
Holy shit!
That's so scary!
Oh my god!
I'm in the woods.
I'm behind a tree right now watching your every movement.
Wait, there's another tree!
I'm watching your every move!
This map is so hard!
Oh dear!
I love that you backed yourself into a corner!
What shall we do?
Fruit, where...
I'm looking at you.
Why are you running to the left, Fruit?
Why are you running that way?
I stopped with something over here.
You're going to the light.
You're going to let you hear those hoop steps right now.
Why is it so dark?
This is a horror game!
I'm not even joking!
That's right!
Why is it so dark?
Holy crap, it's so dark!
I'm crouching in the bushes now!
I'm watching your every move.
Welcome to the sun!
Right there!
I'm not alone!
What?
You have one more sanity point left.
Now you're going to lose.
This map is actually so hard!
Come on, Fruit!
Are you my friend?
It's time for the next game!
Why don't you come into this tent with some pumpkins?
Oh my god, you're actually in...
I thought you were in every scene!
Fruit!
Wake up!
The skinwalkers are here!
Holy crap!
You missed out on this amazing event!
Are you teabagging me?
Yo, deadass though, there is a tent in there and inside of it are a bunch of scary ass jack-o-lanterns.
And I was just standing on two feet being like, welcome come in.
Oh shit!
That was like the scariest game I've played all year.
That is the true horror experience.
It's true.
I think I have hoophobia.
Oh hey, that's the title of the game!
That's the title of the game!
Wrong game!
Wrong game.
Oh, it's Amelie!
Oh no, I glistened the glass again!
Oh no!
Whatever will we do?
It's time to use those apex skills.
Time to shake my ass.
Holy crap!
Worth it!
If you'll excuse me, I'm going to retire now.
I'm chewing.
Don't worry, he's definitely not crawling towards another deer.
I'm just gonna shake.
Oh!
He's definitely not crawling to another deer waiting to get revived.
Nope.
That's not what I'm doing.
Nope, he's not doing that.
That's right, you should- What the fuck?!
The reflex!
Holy shit!
Excuse me.
I'm gonna keep...
That's right.
Guys, I'm so safe.
Don't worry, I'm so safe.
She is like not near me at all.
Guys, I'm in the...
I'm in the river.
Just start grazing on my body and I'll be okay.
It's gonna be so natural.
Where are you?
Come out, come out wherever you are.
She can't see me, I'm in the water.
Are you scared?
She's terrifying for you.
We'll body block.
You remember that scene from Toy Story 1 where all the dead toys were crawling to the same cat's you?
You're safe now.
I can't get out of the river.
What are you doing?
Which one is fruit?
It's me.
I'm fruit.
We're all fruit here.
Oh no.
I might not have my fruit list anymore.
But I have my passion.
You're going crazy.
We're all fruit here.
Looks like we're all fruit here.
Yeah.
Bro, whatever we get on our two legs is just so fucking scary.
It's so scary.
It's always scary when you're not looking at the deer and you just hear the footsteps coming from behind you.
Yeah.
It is.
It's so loud too.
You never know which is the right one.
Oh, back where it all started.
Going back to school.
That's why we banned all the rules.
Hey guys, how about we give them an education?
What the fuck?
How did you die already?
Dude.
I didn't see that she was right there.
Dude, sigh.
I was just excited.
I was excited about deer school.
I'm gonna camp your body.
You're a whore.
That's so fucked up.
Get away from me, you freak.
Bro, how could you do that to him?
He's just trying to be a deer.
He's trying to go to deer high.
He's trying to get an education.
Yeah, he's trying to get a degree.
Get away from me.
I can't believe it.
Now he's gonna be held back and it's gonna be your fault.
What will his dear parents say?
Oh.
He has no future.
Get away from me.
I don't like you.
Go away.
Ain't nobody gonna revive you.
Oh shit, did you get her?
Are you limping?
Run!
Save yourself!
Don't be a hero!
I'm falling.
Oh no.
I'm falling off of Lego bridge.
Guys, get behind the tree.
We will do the tree strat.
It's always worked.
Oh fruit.
The tree strat.
Yeah.
Wait, where are ya?
I don't know.
Maybe she gotcha again.
Gotcha.
I'm in your right motion.
Could this be you fruit?
Are you shaking your booty?
I'm shaking my booty.
What happened?
Are you entertained?
Woah,
that was perfect.
What the frick?
God damn it.
That deer followed me.
Oh.
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Come on fruit.
Don't be scared.
I gotta shake my ass first.
Are you not up?
You're alive!
You're alive Zy!
Wait, what?
I'm not alive.
I gen revive you like two times.
Hey, don't look at me.
I'm still flopping around like a big guy.
I can't believe it.
This is why you flunked out of deer high.
Why do you think I was trying to get educated?
This is exactly why you flunked out.
Don't worry.
I got you.
You are...
Oh fruit!
All I'm saying Zy is that fruit was an easy run.
Yeah.
I'm not that easy.
Did you ever think about that?
Oh!
Here we go.
It's time to cast.
I want to shoot an eye out.
I'm from the tree guys.
Yay.
We contributed.
You can actually teabag when you're still up.
It's so funny.
I tried to.
I am free.
I didn't do shit.
I'm just part of the group.
Yay.
Tiny got it.
Oh no.
Please don't hunt that.
God damn it.
If you say please don't hunt that, you're gonna get hunted.
I'm a hunter.
Oh you're going in the corner.
I'm a deer just like you guys.
Okay never mind.
Oh man.
I see you.
You should do a gotcha pull.
Anyone who gets close to me, I'm shooting.
Yeah do a gotcha pull.
Test your luck.
Come on.
I bet you have good luck.
It's just one shot.
Oh god no.
I have the worst luck.
It's just one shot.
Yeah.
Why are you scared of one shot?
Come on.
It's one out of five shots.
Why do I feel like the one shot is actually going to get us?
Test it.
I hope you get side.
That would be so funny if you use that one shot.
Take that one shot right now.
Take that one shot.
AHHHHH I knew it was you.
I was gonna shoot.
I knew that was you.
I should have shot.
I told you.
You should have done it.
My luck was on my side there.
It was right there.
Take that shot now.
Take that shot.
Wow.
You almost had me.
What the fuck?
Wait did my character just say the F word?
How did you get me?
Hey.
Not to alarm anyone.
But uh.
You kicked me out of the map.
Yeah.
I think it was like back there.
Wait look at him.
It's so funny.
I'm gonna explore the...
I'm gonna explore the outside world.
No.
Oh my god.
Are you seeing things?
This is the trippiest shit ever.
I'm falling off.
You like off the map?
Bro I am literally falling.
Bro.
I am in another world now.
Oh my god.
Did you see that?
Where is he?
I'm deer.
I'm leaving.
See this is what happens when you let me play a game.
I have the tendency to break these fucking things.
I'm just saying.
I think this game is pretty broken.
Emily is definitely not heading towards me.
She was more early on in the game.
I'm gonna head to the bushes.
Yeah so I can break them all.
I'm in there.
You stay away from me.
Where are you?
Which one is the real deer?
And I sure wish I could see my friends playing the deer game.
Should have fallen through the map.
I was like you following me as I crawl around the floor.
Yep.
Why do you guys do that?
Oh my god.
You Which one are you?
We are gonna start standing up.
We are gonna get our two legs.
I can't believe it.
Bro, Fruit has the luckiest scotch out of all of us right there.
That was so lucky.
I wasted my gacha for the...
Well, it's time for a paranoid old man.
There he is.
I'm gonna step on your line.
Please don't.
Don't play!
I said no!
You're surrounded.
I could be that deer right next to you right now.
That's right.
Oh, look at him.
Left and right.
Look at him go.
I still don't know what the timer is.
Shooting random things I see.
Yeah.
Come on.
Do your gacha pull.
Just do a gacha pull.
Yeah, do a gacha pull.
Come on.
If my chat gives subs, I'll shoot blindly right now.
How many gifted subs?
Do the pull.
Maybe you'll get the pity.
Just for five.
That'd be fun.
You'll get the pity right there.
I'm crazy.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
I dare you.
I double dare you.
I triple dare you.
You're getting awfully close there.
Hey, thanks for the five gifted, you'll want...
Oh!
Well, well!
Okay, you're getting the pity.
You're lucky I'm a match.
That's right.
You can't even get me.
You look mighty good in orange.
Ooh, are you gonna look at that boulder now?
Whoever comes out of that boulder might be me.
I'm gonna do it.
The boulder.
Do it!
Distracting him!
Go, go, go!
Oh, God!
You missed him!
We're moving in.
Wait, Emily, are you...
Are you dead?
Nope.
No, Emily's just a...
Oh, shit!
It's crouching next to me.
You're lucky I'm a bad shot!
You missed again, old man!
That's right.
I'm an old man.
Oh, damn.
Bro, what are you doing with that other deer fruit?
What are you...
I don't know!
My cap freaked out.
What are you doing with that other deer?
Come on, Ty, you're in the corner!
Are you scared?
I'm not fucking scared!
You're in the corner!
Come on!
That's me over there.
That's me.
Okay, I...
Ow!
Dude, I...
My leg!
What the fuck?
I'm...
Bro, I shot three different times.
Chat, you saw that.
My bullets weren't working.
My bullets weren't working!
I don't know.
Maybe you were just missing.
What are you shooting at?
Where are you shooting at?
I'm shooting at that deer!
I got it!
Where are you shooting at?
Bro...
Wait.
Is there no deer there for you guys?
There was never a deer there.
No.
All the deer are on that one side of the map right now.
No, you're shooting at nothing.
We were shooting at nothing.
Alright, alright, but no one trample me.
Yeah, no problem.
This?
I shot you!
At different times!
I stopped you, chat!
You all saw it!
I shot that deer!
That specific deer!
At different times!
I don't know, maybe you're doing this...
Game is beyond rigged!
I don't know, maybe you just missed.
Maybe you were missing.
What?
Did he shot you guys?
No, yeah!
He got both of us somehow!
He got both of you guys!
Not me!
That's fucking karma, you sons of bitches!
He did not get me!
But he got both of you!
He did!
What the...
Oh, you're just joking.
For a second I thought you were levitating.
I was like, oh!
Boing, boing, boing!
Boom!
You've got to be fucking kidding me!
You never get me!
I'm like that... what's that whale story?
The Moby Dick, I'm your Moby Dick right now!
Yeah!
This is such bullshit!
The walking animation is so funny!
I'm your Moby Dick!
You'll never catch me!
I'm stuck!
You're walking...
Bro, I don't know what it is!
Oh, no!
No!
I got you, you son of a bitch!
Bro!
I'm...
I am telling you, I shot you five different times!
Just get good!
Oh my god!
Hi, are you ready?
Back where it started.
You want this to be LG?
Oh, brother!
Is that Psy again?
Oh, I knew it!
I'm not going to live this shit down, fellas!
LG on Psy!
Let's go!
Life begins after school!
That's where we've been!
All the rules!
Oh, there they are!
There they are!
I'm shaking my booty for you!
Just like deer hide!
Oh, my god!
My throne has...
How much screaming I did!
The place where we belong!
He didn't get the good pause!
You guys are too close!
Psy, are you scared?
Yeah, why are you so scared?
Don't make me jump on top of my RV!
Get down from the RV, old man!
You're going to break your back!
RV, you say?
You're awfully close!
Shoot him!
That's me!
Shoot it!
Take the shot!
Oh, dude!
Now you'll never know if that one...
If any other deer is going to be me now!
Now you'll never know!
You see that deer over there that you're looking at?
Take the shot!
That's me!
That's me right there!
Come on!
Do it!
That's me!
Take the shot!
That deer you're looking at!
You're so paranoid!
He's so fucking scared!
I'm a pig!
I sold Hunter's sanity!
You should have taken the shot!
Oh!
Where did you go?
You only got one shot!
You only got one shot at deer high!
Oh my god!
Hey, that deer that's really close to you...
Take the shot!
Take it!
Come on!
That's me right there!
I'm losing my goddamn mind here, fellas!
Take that shot!
That deer!
That's me right here!
Come on!
Take the shot!
You know you want to!
You should have taken the shot when you had to!
No!
He took the shot!
There's one of you motherfuckers left!
Oh, now you're going crazy!
Oh!
Oh no!
Yeah!
Yay!
Wait, you're like slow and you're like on your...
Oh my god.
He took the shot!
My god!
He actually did it!
That was fun!
I don't know about you, but...
Yeah, this is so much fun.
This is amazing.
This is great.
I love this game.
This is what this game is all about.
They gotta increase the player...
Oh yeah!
That would be so fun.
The player size and more maps.
I think it would be so fun.
It's still early access.
I definitely like the imposter one the most.
That one was my favorite game though.
That was the best.
And GG's!
Thank you for joining me!
Yeah!
Super fun!
GG's!
I had a great time!
I never laughed so much in my life.
I know!
It was super chaotic.
I think my favorite part was just making Sy so fucking paranoid.
Well, it worked!
You know, I looked at you...
I hope you have wonderful dreams.
I was so close to you for so long, but you never took the shot.
I do!
She was saying take the shot.
That was actually her the whole time.
I do!
I was so happy!
Oh my god!
That was so good!
GG's!
Thank you everybody!
Thanks for having me!
I'll see you guys later guys!
Bye!
Oh my god!
That was so fun!
I'm glad to be able to try out this game.
Yeah, this is early access.
When the game first came out, it was like...
I don't know.
When the game first came out, it was just like no multiplayer servers.
Or private servers.
So I was like waiting.
When I saw that they finally had private servers, I was like...
Oh my god, this is going to be so fun.
I definitely enjoyed the imposter one the most.
That one was so fun!
That was so fun with all the deers.
Yeah!
I'm glad to be able to try it out guys.
And I hope you guys had fun.
I had fun with...
Sy, Amelie, and Fruit.
I had a great time with them.
Let me swap screens real quick.
Oh my god!
I laughed so much and screamed so much.
My voice is dying already.
Holy shit!
But yeah guys!
Did you guys see the new emotes?
I added more... these are all like placeholder emotes.
Until like I actually have new emotes.
I haven't like...
commissioned any new emotes yet.
Because I won't wait until...
I'm waiting until like we have...
We have our new skin suit.
Because I don't want to commission them and then be like, oh shit now I have to like redo all my emotes.
So that's why we haven't got them yet.
Hey!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I only tuned in for an hour.
But that was so much fun!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm glad you guys enjoyed it guys.
Von!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Crying in European times.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's like the hardest part about streaming.
Just like... um...
Just like...
Trying to find like times for everybody that will work for everyone.
That's why we like redid our...
um... um... changed our schedule lineup a bit to have it today instead of tomorrow.
Because it fit everybody's schedule.
Because I was like, oh my gosh if we play this one we should have a full party.
Because um...
Obviously it's going to be more chaotic.
And it will be more fun to have...
Jesus!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Jesus!
Can you like...
Uncopyright strike my charity stream?
Jesus!
Can you...
Can you tell the church to remove the copyright claim?
So I can like...
Um... the placeholders are beautiful too.
I can't wait for the new skin suit and emos.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh... uh...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Doki please introduce... I saw that and I was like...
Oh shit sorry we got too...
Into the game and we forgot to introduce ourselves.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Jordan!
This reminds me of the time I went hunting.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yeah if your hunting trip is like that, you might need to go to the doctor.
So you might need to You might need to get yourself checked real quick.
Uh... Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yeah very, very accurate hunting simulator.
Uh... Galio!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Your mom.
Um...
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Who's the average for democracy?
I think my favorite part was just the 360.
The 360...
Every time I was just...
I was using movement on everybody with the with the 360 uh... jump.
It's just the 360 like... Oh you can't catch me!
You can't catch me!
360 no dear.
Why?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Is ketchup a sauce or a gravy?
It's a sauce!
Um...
Uh... Tell us thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I love another stream for this game.
That was hilarious.
I laughed so much.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I think like um... Definitely in the future for this game, I'm gonna wait until there's more uh... There's more like modes to it and more like maps and stuff.
Because like...
It's definitely a one off.
This is uh... This is definitely a one off game because um... At a point it gets... It gets old.
We play it too long.
Uh...
Yeah.
When there's more content in there, it'd definitely be more fun.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I was surprised that you didn't run when the hunter was looking away so that they would be more paranoid when they hear hooves and stomp after a bit.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I was like... I was tempted to just like...
say next... Like run around him and just stay there.
Hahahaha!
Uh... Where's... Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Um...
Let's see... Where was I?
Uhhhh...
Uh... Omega!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
This is my first ever super.
Keep up the good work.
Don't worry.
Saying my...
Saying my username wrong.
Don't worry.
I read half your username.
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
I forgot to say I forgot to put up the text that I'm reading.
Donation.
Don... It's donation.
It's super chat reading time.
Um...
Zonnerman!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Despite being native, I've never been hunting so thanks for showing me part of my heritage.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Do not worry.
This is the real hunting experience guys.
Hahaha!
For those who have never...
Guys!
I can... I bet you I have some vouchers in my chat.
This is how hunting is all about guys.
This is...
This is the true hunting experience.
Like if you're...
If the deers don't stand up on their two feet, that's not real hunting.
That's not real hunting.
You gotta watch out for those skinwalkers.
They're right there.
Hahaha!
They could be any one of us.
It's like that adventure time.
Um...
That adventure time.
Uh... uh... deer meme where he takes off his hose and he's like...
Hahaha!
Uh...
Uh... wait!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm in Europe.
Night shift lets me watch... Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yeah, trying to... get like... I always have like a very consistent stream schedule.
So most of the time it's just usually like 5pm PST and 12.30pm PST.
And if I collabs with people on the other side of the world, obviously it's gonna be a little later.
Um... so I do try to keep it very consistent.
Um...
But I do apologize for people on the other side of the world because...
Hahaha!
It's not...
My streams for them is like super early in the morning.
So like... I do apologize for that.
My usual streams.
Uh... let's see.
Endwatcher Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Only the tomato skin is expensive.
Not the skin.
So thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
But speaking of like...
Uh... streams on the other side of the world.
Uh... streams for the people on the other side of the world.
I will be collabing next week with... uh...
Ditto, Uto, and RPR I think.
We're doing Lethal Company next week.
I think we are.
We're still setting that up but I assume it was supposed to be this week.
But there's so many stuff happening for me this week that we decided to move it to next week.
So we're still deciding the date and the time.
But we'll be playing Lethal Company for next week.
Uh... but yeah!
That's... I think that's...
I mean... it's really hard because I try to organize... I try not to like... stuff... so the thing about this was like I'm planning on doing a stream talking about like how I... my mind works when it comes to streaming.
But like... um...
the best advice I can give people is that... this is like a sneak peek to this like the stream that I'm planning that I've been writing notes for about like... um... making... not just VTubing but like content creation.
I try not to put too many collabs in one week.
But if there is a lot of collabs in for a week, I balance it out with more solo streams.
Um... because you don't want to have two more collabs than solo streams.
And it's more so like... um... you try to do...
for me right now, my...
uh... for me right now I try to have like at least one to two collabs a week.
Um... just to get started.
Uh... I think you might notice that this is a similar pattern when I first uh... when I first started streaming.
Um...
When I first started... not first started streaming but when I first started being serious with streaming.
When I kicked things off.
Because when you're first starting out, you have to get your name out there.
So like collabing is a great way to do that.
And um... and so you I had like a whole thing where I was like every week I would like to have at least one collab.
Just to get my name out there.
And to like uh... make people know who I am because I was new.
I was new in the...
basically new in the world.
Uh...
So like because like now I'm restarting my career again.
So that's why I try to make sure like every week I have at least one to two collabs.
Um... if I don't have two collabs I have like something like you know the tournaments or something.
Because that's considered a collab.
Um...
So it's more so of like uh... like every week I want at least one collab with someone.
Um... and it's good to like networking.
Uh... and despite me being an introvert I try my best to socialize as much as I can.
.
Um... Chris thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I couldn't be more proud of you and your new journey.
I can't have I tried.
Can't wait to 100% my Doki...
You'll never.
You'll never 100% your Doki shrine.
But you can try.
You can have 99% because you'll never beat me.
It'll never be 100% because you'll never beat me.
Keep doing your best.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't really wait for the intro to collab again.
Is it coming...
Is it still coming soon?
Um...
I'm just uh... it is soon TM.
Soon TM.
I don't have really have any updates other than the last time I showed it.
Sean thank you for the magenta suit.
Thank you.
It was a great game.
It was funny.
Especially the dear Fomia.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the magenta suit.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
But yeah I think like right now...
Osai!
Welcome to the TM!
Welcome!
Thank you!
Thank you for joining Osai.
I hope you had a great time being paranoid now.
Now you trust me less.
I could be right behind you right now.
Um...
What was I saying?
Oh yeah I think the hardest part about...
Also like the reason why I've been like trying to like reach out to as many different people as possible to collab is that I want to try and find like...
I want to have like a consistent group to have.
And so like if I ever want to do more group collabs I can easily like hit people up for it.
Because there's a lot of group games I really really want to do.
Like I want to do like Trouble in Terrace Town again and stuff like that.
So I want to like get to know as many people as possible in the community and um... and cause like you know it's harder as an indie I think to have a consistent group of people to play with.
And a consistent group of people to like hit up and stuff to play.
And like the thing is I have a lot of people I know and a lot of people I'm friends with outside uh like not just like in the indie VTuber scene not just in the VTuber scene but like outside the VTuber scene.
But like the risky part is like mixing that group of people.
So like I always try to keep it consistent like oh like VTuber collabs and then collabs outside mix collabs and stuff like that.
So um and like uh...
I try to expand my network and meet as many people as possible so I can have like consistent people I wanna do collabs with or like wanna do group games with cause like there's so many fun multiplayer games that I really really wanna do.
And um... I wanna have like a group of like people I can hit up on easily.
Be like you wanna do this game?
You wanna do that game?
Um so a lot of people I'm like interacting with for the first time or like uh haven't interacted really much before.
Never had a chance to do collab with.
So it's a lot... my social battery
I'm trying my best.
Anyway I'm gonna read like three more super chats and then I'm gonna call it here.
Because I need to rest my voice for tomorrow.
Cause we do have a stream tomorrow.
Um... let's see.
Uh oh yeah by the way.
By the way um... Tempo confirmed to me that because I made it to the finals I can't participate in the other tournaments.
I only go straight to the final tournament.
I'm like no!
I'm like I was like I should have threw but then I like bracket I'm joking.
I was like I should have I should have threw my game bracket I'm joking bracket.
I was like no!
I really wanted to do the third.
I really wanted to do the third one.
The third one looked so fun.
But the finals they have it too.
No!
The free money!
But were you serious about joking?
Nami thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I'm sure you'll find a lot of people you've been working hard on.
Thank you thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I always get like a lot of anxiety right before the collab.
Um because like obviously like when I'm collabing people... even if it's like with people I'm like used to collabing with.
Like if it's like a ditto collab or something like that.
I still get a lot of anxiety right before like an hour before the collab.
I just need you guys to know when I woke up I ate lunch and then I took a four hour nap right before the stream.
I really woke up at like 4.30.
I was so stressed out.
I was just like really tired.
I was just like alright wake up food.
Oh wait brush teeth.
Food.
And then I was like
And then I was like okay.
And then my dad was like Doki!
It's 4.
It's 4.40!
Wake up!
I was like okay.
I did it.
I always get really nervous because the thing about collabs is that versus a solo stream is that you can't control what happens in a collab.
You don't know what's gonna happen.
You don't know what the chemistry is gonna be like.
Especially with people you don't you've never played with before.
So it's more so like oh you don't know what the chemistry is gonna be like.
You don't know what the what the what the game is gonna be like.
If it's a new game you've never played with before.
And all that stuff.
So I always get super anxious right before the collab.
I know it doesn't look like it.
Like you know fake it till you make it.
That's like my whole thing.
My entire streaming career.
has been majority fake it till you make it.
Cause like people don't know I'm an introvert when I first started.
And it's like no I'm a full on introvert.
But like I'm very good at faking it.
So yeah.
Anyway I'm gonna go call it here guys.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!